after the defeat of General rodon a path
will open leading to the Eternal City
among its denizens we find a wretched
set of creatures wielding the cool white
ghost flame as we enter the Eternal City
we see this creepy creature in droves
with bloodied hands and feet and dried
out flesh wielding the ghost flame torch
and some meager armaments this is the
company of the Fallen Hawks another one
of Elden Ring's blatant berserk
references and the subject of today's
video as we get into our lower
discussion feel free to subscribe to the
channel as it helps me make these videos
in more ways than one with that sit back
and enjoy the tale of the Fallen Hawks
we immediately see that the Fallen Hawks
are a gnarly Bunch making them a perfect
topic to discuss starring the spookiest
time of the year their limbs are
bloodied their bodies are emaciated and
they even seem to have some
frankenstein-esque bolts on their heads
these bolts may be traces of lost
helmets which were perhaps attached to
their very skulls when we come across
these withered whites we may note that
they are digging at the ground looking
for something they've dug so much with
their bare hands that they've worn off
their skin leaving only Trace Amounts of
red flesh on their appendages this enemy
does not have much description but they
do have a few tidbits of lore in their
gear and their conspicuous ghost playing
torch the torch is the Cornerstone of
the story reading metal torch that burns
with cold ghost flame tool of the Fallen
Hawks who prowl the underground Rivers
when the band's last Embers were used up
in their long search they began to burn
the bones of their fellows acquiring the
cold ghost flame but sealing their fate
as dwellers of the underground for all
eternity this is the core of the Fallen
Hawk Story the description of their
downfall they came to nokran and the
show for aqueduct for some investigation
but they ran out of supplies namely
things to burn so they turned to the
only kindling they had their own flesh
another example of the game's theme of
Flesh kindling it's unclear whether the
Hawks killed some of their comrades to
burn their bones or that some of them
had just died naturally but either way
this bone burning brought them the ghost
flame and as the ghost flame is a
contrasting Force to the herd tree and
greater will check out my Raven Mountain
video for more on that the Hawks were
cursed for acquiring the heretical flame
they were doomed to remain underground
forever and considering death ain't much
of a thing anymore in the lands between
that meant wasting away into the forms
we find them as the ghostly torch is
also noteworthy because it features an
upturned skull the bones of the Hawks
are being used in real time as kindling
for the flame further emphasizing the
spooky and blasphemous aspect of their
new light source the dead Hawks Supply
the flame but they also serve another
use there are Spirit ashes that feature
some of the Fallen Fallen Hawks the
great Shield Soldier ashes say that they
lob ghost flame and the Archer ashes
feature Arrows imbued with cold ghost
flame so the Hawks embraced ghost flame
more than just using the torch maybe
this happened after they were condemned
to life underground and they saw no
reason to avoid the new Power they
already hit rock bottom they couldn't go
any lower we can actually find the
arrows as item drops from the still
living Fallen Hawks they are called
Spirit flame arrows but as confirmed by
the red Scholars English Japanese
spreadsheet the kanji is the same as for
ghost flame so we could also just call
these ghost flame arrows after all even
their in-game description refers to them
as such reading arrow set a light with
ghost flame before firing deals magic
damage while also afflicting foes with
frost used by the company of the Fallen
Hawk once ordered to explore the Eternal
City here we also get some more lore the
Fallen Hawks were not just some random
band of explorers investigating the
Eternal City they were a random band of
explorers ordered to investigate the
Eternal City we can learn even more
about this Expedition from a shield some
of the Hawks carry called the inverted
Hawk heater Shield it reads a
medium-sized metal shield easier to
handle than a kite Shield the inverted
Hawk is the emblem of the company of
slaves ordered to explore the Eternal
City this gives us a fuller picture of
the Hawks not as Noble explorers but
slaves forced to Embark underground
without enough supplies for their
Journey the fact that the hawk emblem on
their Shield is inverted May indicate
either their Journey below the surface
or their status as slaves it appears on
their inverted Hawk Tower Shield as well
but this Shield's description doesn't
offer up any more lore if the Hawks are
slaves then it Bears asking who is their
master who sent them underground to
explore the Eternal City there are a few
candidates for explanation but nothing
we can say for certain first there's the
crust they bear the inverted Hawk along
with their corresponding title as Fallen
Hawks the hawk is a symbol of stormvale
as we read from the hawk Crest wooden
Shield a tall medium-sized wooden Shield
light for its size and easy to handle
adorned with a long forgotten crest of
Stormville ancient in Design This Shield
does note that it is easy to handle
somewhat like the inverted Hawk heater
Shield there are plenty of Hawk
Connections in Stormville from the storm
Hawk King to the grafted Hawks to the
true storm bringing back a host of hawks
when nepheli takes the throne if this is
the connection then the Fallen Hawks may
have once been soldiers of Stormville
maybe they serve the stormlord that
Godfrey faced if so we would have an
explanation as to their slavery soldiers
of the old Lord they could have been
bound and chained with their Lord's
defeat we know the golden order is okay
with slavery from its treatment of the
Miss begotten and the trolls so
absorbing soldiers of a defeated enemy
as slaves is par for the course I'm not
sure where the consensus is when it
comes to the stormlord but a sensible
enough reading to me would be that the
stormlord is an ancient ruler of
Stormville that was defeated by Godfrey
if Godfrey then took the storm Throne he
could have sent the Fallen Hawks as his
Newfound slaves to explore the Eternal
City an area which served as banishment
grounds for the greater will this
telling of things also justifies why
nepheli Liu daughter of horalu brings
back the true storm and its Hawks when
she takes the throne it explains the
storm connection from Godfrey this also
gives a good explanation for the Fallen
Hawks too most of the aspects of their
story From Slavery to Hawk connection
get some justification but of course
this is not the only option as argued
strongly by some users in the eldering
Discord there is one aspect of the
stormvale route that is lacking why were
the Hawks sent to nokron specifically
all of the Eternal cities and Knox went
against the golden order but the Fallen
Hawks were sent to explore only nokron
this is even more important because of
what can be found there the Finger
Slayer Blade the pivotal Blade's
description reads the hidden treasure of
the Eternal City of norcron a blade said
to have been born of a corpse The
blood-drenched Fetish is proof of the
high treason committed by the Eternal
City and symbolizes its downfall cannot
be wielded by those without a fate but
is said to be able to harm the greater
will and its vassals the blade is needed
to complete Ronnie's questline and in
game we can find EG and blive searching
for a path to necron EG even says that I
take it you've heard of the Eternal City
of Knox Stella well
it has a twin
known as nokron
the other
Eternal City
after years of expeditions
we've determined the location of macron
by Going Underground through the well in
the Mist wood of lim grave
you can see no cron up above only we
failed to find a path leading to the
City blinds made a good go of it but I'm
afraid this has him quite stumped to be
honest
I'm not sure where to go from here
the line about years of expeditions
makes it sound like the exploration of
the Hawks but the fact that they haven't
found a path seems odd yes the Hawks
didn't make it back to the surface to
tell of their path but if the Hawks were
in Ronnie's charge it's weird to not
have followed up on their disappearance
it would make sense for Ronnie or
possibly her ancestors to have sent a
search party to nokron to find the blade
and we can see that the Fallen Hawks are
still searching for something in the
city maybe they found the city but their
exploration did not reach its end they
might have lost their minds but they
still hold on to the one idea that drove
them there the search for the Finger
Slayer blade and they keep digging
mindlessly propelled by that one drive
to me this explanation is weaker we
don't get any info on any of the hawk
connections and it's never stated that
the carrions had slaves they even saw
their trolls as equals with the troll
knight sword telling of how they are
treated as true Knights of karya and
fight arm in arm with their human
comrades as such the Fallen Hawks being
ordered as slaves down Into the Depths
seems out of place this brutal treatment
is more in line with the golden order
and I think we could even extend the
Finger Slayer blade searching to the
order too maybe they knew something of
nokon's treasure and its ability to harm
the greater will and its vassals this
could have motivated them to send the
Fallen Hawks to search for it and this
would again explain the Hawks and their
obsessive digging though there are a lot
of moving Parts either way from the
carrions to the stormlord so if there is
anything I missed or a conclusion that
seems unjustified due to other evidence
feel free to mention it in the comments
the Fallen Hawks are one of the most
visually striking humanoids in the game
not for any imposing or Supernatural
element but for their classic horror
look their wilted swollen State like
zombies in a permanent stasis of
starvation their bodies eternally
wasting away the head bolts missing eyes
and Crimson appendages don't help the
picture either to me they stand as one
of the game's creepiest enemies and the
lore of their enslaved investigation
matches that unnerving design they would
be right at home as a lesser creature in
one of H.P lovecraft's short stories and
they do a great job of delivering that
kind of spookiness to the underground of
the lands between if this lore
investigation of the Hawks investigation
is your kind of thing consider
subscribing to the channel or becoming a
patron on patreon both really helped me
make these videos by justifying my time
and effort with higher digital numbers
effectively unlocking my dopamine
receptors I'll be making more videos
focusing on spookiness for the rest of
October so I'll hope to see you there
with that thanks for watching and bye